da legt man voller Euphorie sechs Eier
in einen Brutautomaten und was passiert
rein gar nichts aber warum mit der
Taschenlampe haben wir wie Hobby
Sherlocks die Eier untersucht und der
Züchter hatte mich schon vorgewahnt sein
Hahn ist im Winter wohl eher eine
Frostbeule als ein Casanova und ja die
Eier waren nicht befruchtet also habe
ich auf Ebay ein paar neue seltene
Bruteier ergattert von Ryan dotton
olivlegern und schwedischen Raritäten
jetzt sind 26 neue Hoffnungsträger im
Brutautomaten manche von euch meinten
ich soll lieber ausgediente legehänden
vor dem Suppentopf retten als neue
auszubrüten wir haben auch schon über 20
gerettete Seniorinnen aufgenommen und
Ihnen einen schönen Lebensabend
geschenkt aber wir halten die Hühner
auch zur Selbstversorgung mit Eiern und
junge Hühner legen nun mal deutlich mehr
Eier deswegen finde ich es überhaupt
nicht verwerflich auch neue Hühner
aufzuziehen gerade wenn man so alte
Rassen erhalten kann wenn ihr
mitbekommen wollt wie bald hoffentlich
endlich Küken schlüpfen dann folgt mir
gerne und jetzt erstmal Daumen drücken